hi there steve kaufman again here i'm
back from my uh ski holiday uh had a
great time at big white mostly uh
cross-country skiing
uh and i want to talk a little bit more
again about stephen krashen for two
reasons one because there was a
very interesting thread on a forum
scott thornberry i think his name is
i will post a link at my blog the
linguist on language blog so you can go
there and
join this discussion about crashing
stephen krashen
let me say that i think that his work
and the influence that he's had is
is extremely significant
there's some discussion on this thread
in this forum the one that i'm
referring to and that i'm going to post
a link to at my blog
some suggestion that his influence has
been uh you know exaggerated or that
there's been too much reference to him
and so forth
and and i believe that there's not
enough there's nowhere near enough the
vast majority of
of teachers of teaching institutions
that i have come across
do not apply his principles even though
his reference to his principles
apparently is a staple uh in what people
learn at uh at uh you know language
teaching institutions around the world
so
people are not using his principles
effectively in my view
and so he is a great person a great man
in terms of how he has described what
goes on in language learning and the
research that he has done which i
haven't done i mean i'm just an amateur
in all of this
uh so yet there are areas as i've said
before where i i disagree and i just
want to mention some of his a few of his
sort of uh the the aspects of his
uh theory of language acquisition and
and and how i think it relates at least
in my experience
one of his theories is that and i'll get
this all wrong but i'll you can search
for him on the internet and draw your
own conclusions but he talks about um
first of all that uh that if we spend
too much time on grammar that that
becomes
it's sort of like a monitor and if we
have to go through this monitor all the
time we won't be able to speak naturally
and i certainly agree
that the rules are just there to kind of
make us more attentive but if we try to
remember the language via rules if we
try to think through the rules each time
we want to speak we won't get very far
uh and as i've said before i'm quite
happy to
have things in a text remain uncertain
to me i won't go and search the grammar
rule i'll just
soldier on so i think his monitor theory
as in other words as i understand it in
other words don't become too reliant on
grammar or you'll always have to go to
this monitor every time you want to
say something or understand something
he talks about effective filters like
feelings that we have that prevent us
from learning and that is certainly true
and and i've talked about this as a
major issue for adults who are afraid to
sound childish who are
otherwise inhibited and prevented from
just communicating and taking the
language in the way children do
so i would agree with them there
he talks about and others do as well
there's reference to vesatsuki i think
his name is
uh famous uh russian uh
writer on education this whole idea that
we want that proximate level that
i plus one the to the extent that we are
in just that next level of difficulty uh
we are going to do well in our learning
uh i think even the whole flow theory
apply you know refers to that and i
won't even try to pronounce the name of
this
nihilist whatever hungarian writer who
wrote about
flow in other words if you're in a
situation where whatever you're
attempting to do is just a little
difficult for you and you are able to do
it you have a great sense of
satisfaction and achievement you're in a
powerful motivated learning
mood
the only thing i would say to that is
that to me
if we are input-based language learners
then the selection of what to use as
content to my mind
uh it's more motivating and therefore
better for me
to have content that is interesting
rather than just to have content that's
just a little bit difficult so i have a
very boring text
that's just a little bit difficult but
it's of no interest to me that doesn't
do me much good
and particularly nowadays that we don't
have to rely on a conventional book with
a conventional dictionary we can read on
the internet we can hear the audio
uh we can learn words and phrases retain
them and view them all these other tools
make it possible to take on content that
is that not i plus one but i plus five
uh if we are motivated to learn and to
fight our way through that content so to
that extent i disagree there
uh he also talks about the natural order
that there is a natural order
with which we will learn grammar so that
you can't
learn something until you are ready to
learn it that there is a natural order i
have no idea whether this is true or not
but i do know
that
it is not because a teacher teaches
something or because you deliberately
study something that you're going to
learn it
when
a grammar pattern clicks in and starts
to feel natural is not something that we
control
and that is another reason why i don't
mind not understanding
not getting certain language patterns
and that's another reason why i think
it's not a good idea to test people
based on grammar patterns that have been
taught the fact that it has been taught
doesn't mean that it's going to be
learned it'll click in at some point in
the future
now if you go to the website the lev
reference to krashen's work
you'll notice that a lot of the
discussion refers to what happens in a
classroom
and since i believe that learning takes
place primarily outside the classroom
that the classroom is there only to
stimulate the learner
to
get them turned on to learning
you know i suddenly began to begin to
realize that that really there's sort of
two kinds of learning there's the
feedlot if we think of cattle
there's the feedlot learning
where a bunch of cattle are impend in a
small area
and the rancher feeds them whatever he
wants to feed them and they stand in one
spot and munch on it more or less
whereas the grazing model is that the
cattle or the sheep or whatever they are
they wander all over the place and they
don't stand in one spot and
and and eat the grass until it's bare
although i've never been a cows i don't
know but they seem to i know the image
at least is that they're wandering
around the hillside munching some there
munching some here then they wander back
to the same spot again and munch some
more and that's kind of the image to me
of learning
we do a little bit here we don't want to
and this is the i think the biggest
problem that inexperienced learners have
is that they want to nail things down
they want to eat that grass right down
to their roots they want to try to
master this lesson master this
vocabulary master this grammar
and it is a futile exercise it's
extremely wasteful of your time and
energy and it leads to frustration
it's better you're better to go and and
like you know i'll often recommend to
beginners buy three beginner books
and go through essentially the same
kind of content from three different
approaches or you know if you're a link
take lots of different beginner content
don't necessarily just stay with one
graze around and cover
the same thing in different ways
uh
and and uh go back over things i mean i
have been at russian for three years i
take great delight in going back to my
beginner books
and trying now to and i'm reminding
myself of things that i've learned and
forgotten even though i'm quite capable
of understanding quite difficult stuff i
know i'm going to make mistakes and very
simple things and so i'm able to go back
so you know i think that that
i'm a grazer i'm out exploring
deciding what i want to munch on
wandering the hillside not worrying
about what i leave behind
i'm not a feedlot learner pending
waiting for
the rancher to give me
my
oats or my hay or whatever he's decided
to feed me
or
antibiotics or steroids or whatever he's
going to feed me
so i think a lot of the discussion about
even some of the things that are on that
thread effective filters things that
happen in a classroom
it's quite different if we're out
grazing
so there you have it it's uh
again further discussion on crash i
recommend that you visit this thread get
into this discussion about stephen crash
and the tremendous influence that he has
had
and that he is now applying to the whole
issue of literacy in the united states
where again he's appealing for a more
natural and a pleasurable approach to
improving literacy rather than the
over-teaching that the established
teaching institutions
uh seem to want to impose over teaching
over-testing which is only going to
discourage people from reading so thank
you for listening